these players might have done some
straight up insider trading this is
crazy stuff Copenhagen Flames a Danish
Esports organization recently filed for
bankruptcy they were probably best known
for their CS go team and like any good
CS go team they had plenty of hype
stickers so when someone pointed out
that some players on the team had been
buying their stickers before the
bankruptcy announcement people were
quick to cry insider trading simply put
there will never be another Copenhagen
flame sticker so they're collector's
items now and since the players maybe
could have known about the bankruptcy
ahead of time they might be able to cash
in big time down the line it's an
advantage that no other skin Trader
would have had but to be honest the
price increases haven't been insane so
far so as of right now at least the
players aren't cashing out big time